[Applause]
Master, I am Alejandro Robledo Aburto,
General Director of the Mexican Institute
of Social Security
[Applause]
and Mr. Juan Antonio Ferrer Aguilar,
Director of the Institute of Health for
Welfare
[Applause] Those
who follow us online
through social networks are all
welcome
[Applause]
The 'Miguel Hidalgo' award is the
highest medal awarded by the United States of
Mexico to its nationals to
reward eminent or distinguished merits,
relevant exemplary conduct or life trajectory, services rendered to the
country or to humanity, or heroic acts
in terms of  law on awards,
incentives and civil rewards
the government of the united
mexican states through the awarding council for
the 'miguel
hidalgo' decoration established within its bases
the degrees of the decoration being 4
degree collar is awarded to
medical and nursing staff in  all
levels that have collaborated directly
with clinical care  nica of
kobe 19 patients within covite
cross degree hospitals is awarded to
medical and nursing staff at all
levels who have collaborated directly
in the clinical care of
kobe 19 patients within identified
high-productivity so-called cobit hospitals
for the intense
work days and the effort to
care for critically
ill patients in kobe 19
grade band is awarded to the staff of
the participating institutions who
have worked in cobit hospitals
in any area and who directly or
indirectly contribute
to patient care  sick by kobe 19
regardless of the type of contract and degree
plaque which will be
symbolically placed in kobe hospitals to
recognize all the health personnel
who make them the
miguel hidalgo award is an
allegorical representation of freedom achieved
through  fight represented by a
tri Mexican royal eagle  Unfante
holding a broken chain surrounded
by the sparkles of a star,
Dr. Olga Sánchez Corbo, Secretary
of the Interior, then speaks.
Good morning to all of you. I
respectfully greet the presence
of the President of the United Mexican States,
Mr. Andrés
Manuel, Mr.  López Obrador
also greeted the presence of his
wife, Beatriz Gutiérrez Muller.
I am very pleased that the
President of the Board of Directors of the
Chamber of Deputies and Mariana are with us. You can see
that it is also an honor that
the President of the Chamber of Senators is with us.
óscar eduardo ramírez
and very especially also that
the president of the supreme
court of justice in the nation arturo
saldívar lelo de larrea accompany us as well as I
greet the head of government of the
city of mexico to the general secretary
to the admiral secretary to the secret of
public security  and also to my
colleagues with much love to my
colleagues from gabine  legal and extended tee
who accompany us I
greet all the public servants
who are seeing us and the
general public who are accompanying us via the internet it
is an honor for me to be with you in
this award ceremony for the
miguel hidalgo award
calculation does not make the  hero since an
english cardinal and writer is john
newman and how right he was because like this
without calculation without reserve risking their
lives minute by minute many
public servants of the federal government
and many other people in different
fields have acted
during this pandemic or bill 19 on this
occasion
We will award 58 people, all of them
from the health sector of the federal government,
with the highest distinction granted by the
Mexican state to its nationals. We will
do so at the proposal and application of
patients discharged from this
disease,
as well as health personnel from
various institutions, which without  doubt
makes this recognition something very
special as it has been granted by
colleagues and patients  testified to the
dignified professional and dedicated action
of the health personnel
who, regardless of time, their
own needs, even at the cost of their
own health and risking their lives,
squandered solidarity and empathy in the
professional care of the disease
, all of them are excellent
professionals, but  Above all, they are
Mexican men and women of excellence.
The decision to reward, as the law says,
eminent merits, exemplary conduct or
life trajectories, such
as relevant services or
heroic acts rendered to the country or to
humanity, is only a small
symbol of the enormous recognition that
we have for them. We
celebrate their heroism.  their solidarity and
courage their sense of duty as
health professionals their attitude in
the last line of combat against this
new disease
and I say the last because prevention
should be the first, that is,
we reward their intervention their work in
the daily care of patients who
suffer the consequences of
disease in hospitals and health centers,
those awarded the necklace degree
are undoubtedly heroes and heroines of the
21st century in this health crisis, the
largest and most challenging in the
recent history of humanity,
for this reason the nation recognizes their
heroism and  their commitment is the
act of self-sacrifice and love for
others
, it clearly expresses the values that our c
untry has upheld throughout its h
story but also represents the highe
t ideals of this fourth trans
ormation of public life in mexic
that is  They are nourished by patriotism and the
selfless dedication of
heroic citizens,
so this year 58 decorations will be
awarded as necklaces to
medical doctors and nursing staff
of the different hospitals and
care centers of institutions such as
James El Este and Xavi Sedena Semar.  and
pemex
i feel very proud as president
of the council that awards this
award and as secretary of
g  obernation of being able to honor such
courageous
patriotic people who do their work in a
selfless and committed manner and who have
saved many lives during this
difficult time that our country is experiencing, the
spirit of solidarity of the people of Mexico
has rescued us from the greatest
misfortunes of our history we have
Lost lives is true, but it is also true
that thanks to these brave women and men
, many others have been rescued,
the future is always
uncertain, but I am convinced that if
this future is in the hands of
professionals such as those awarded
today, then it is  a future that
is worth fighting for because you are
full of values of fraternity of honor
and of a civil and solidary society there
is no eros in solitude only the commo
effort generates heroic acts for that reason I hav
no choice but to thank you again for your prese
ce  once again congratulate the
women and men who receive the
miguel hidalgo award in degree of
necklace for being exemplary sons and daughters
of the country and for reminding us that it still
calls me now darker than
tenacious effort to illuminate the thickest of
black congratulations thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
in the framework of the celebration of the 210th
anniversary of  the independence
of mexico today, 58
miguel hidalgo decorations will be awarded
to the medical and
nursing staff at all levels who have
collaborated directly in the
clinical care of patients with kobe 19
within the cobit hospitals
receive row 1 decoration
[Applause]
in the area of health and the Institute of Healt
and Welfare, America Campos León, I say
Alejandro Rivera Mora, nurse
but only Rosas
Hernández, nurse, Ángel Israel Galván Muñoz, nurse
Brasilia del Rosario, Quevedo Street, docto
, Ernesto Castellanos, Flores, nurse
with Salen Martínez-Mariano, docto
nora hilda vega camacho
doctor maría isabel carmona zúñiga
receives in number 2
of l  to secretary of health and health institute
for medical well-being our
alberto delgadillo pliego
doctor omar calderón vale
doctor patricia alejandra meza menezes
nurse pedro pablo jorge scoppa
nurse stephanie del carmen de
tabasco
doctor jorge luís ruiz toledo
israeli nurse the war
doctor hector gonzalo casanova pacheco
and nurse jesús ulises
hernández zacarías
receives in row number 3
from the secretary of health and health institute
for medical welfare josé
efraín ramos martínez
nurse i am not david martínez
gutiérrez
nurse carla daniela ramón sandoval
nurse victoria chantal mesa courtesy
nurse juliet erenia seseña leal
of the secretary of national defense
nurse silvia gabriela aldecoa Ríos
senior surgeon doctor aldo radamés garza
sánchez
senior surgeon doctor alejandro Saledo
Chaves
and doctor alfonso rodríguez jaramillo
row number 4
of the secretary of national defense
senior surgeon eva lorena
ma  rtínez fernández
[Applause]
senior surgeon old cost
gallegos vargas
county assistant nursing assistant
maría teresa vázquez herrera
the awarding council for the
award miguel hidalgo consented
term recognition grants the
posthumous award to the
frigate lieutenant of the naval health service
medical surgeon specialist  in
family medicine luis rey calderón leal who
served at the
naval hospital in the port of veracruz passed away
on july 2, 2020 being a great
companion and human being he was always
ready on the front line of battle
and lost his life fighting against the  cob
and taking care of his patients until the
last day, his
wife, Mrs. Sandra Isela Hernández Salazar, received an award
[Applause]
without any decoration from the Institute of
Security and Social Services
for State Workers, Nurse Tania
Concepción Sánchez Sánchez,
Doctor Alberto Gómez Lara,
Doctor Alejandro Arriola Mora  them
from the mexican institute of medical social security
alberto rosa herrera
and doctor beatriz alejandra from prison
cepeda
receives row number 5
mexican institute of medical social security
this was his dinner fernández
hernández
doctor ana luisa martínez pérez
doctor aldo ariel ponce de léon romo
nurse cristian barrientos  ramírez
nurse elizabeth bustamante rodríguez
nurse jaime leura hernández
doctor when alejandro arredondo
pacheco
doctor jose roberto chávez cruz
and nurse josé iván campo moreno
receive style number 6
from the mexican social security institute
nurse karina del carmen castillo
hernández
[Applause]
doctor giovanna ivonne ruiz cruz
[  Applause]
doctor jorge alejandro morales treviño
doctor jesús manuel armenta belderráin
[Applause]
méxico rubén y sa y montano islands
doctor luis humberto barrón garcía
[Applause]
doctor roberto ibarra infante
doctor is not root lauren
and nurse norma estela colunga mares
receives row  number 7
of the mexican social security institute
nurse rebeca root hernández
[Applause]
nurse maría del rosário juárez
olivares
from petroleum méxicanos doctor sergio
jonathan garcía mortera
[applause]
and doctor ni dialisis heredia gonzález
in honor of those who died from the
pandemic in comic 19 te  offer a
minute of silence
[Music]